st gall pour être one de congédier un
employé pour un comportement survenue à
l'extérieur du travail vérification
faite
oui la loi ontarienne sur les normes de
l'emploi tout comme les lois similaires
du québec ou du canada permettent le
congédiement pour inconduite sim aux
aurait enfreint le code de conduite des
grands one qui dit nous traitons les
employés et les personnes avec
lesquelles nous faisons affaire avec
dignité et respect at the one ne tolère
pas le harcèlement et la discrimination
de plus en plus d'employeurs comme règle
impose un code de conduite à leurs
employés que ceux ci s'engagent à
respecter même à l'extérieur du travail
à l'ère des réseaux sociaux les
compagnies veulent protéger leur
réputation et surtout éviter qu'un
comportement inapproprié ne nuisent au
climat de travail
la démarcation entre ce qui se passe au
travail et à l'extérieur de travail
devient de plus en plus ténue selon les
experts consultés il y habituellement
une progression dans les sanctions
possibles avant d'en arriver au
congédiement
mais il faut désormais savoir que les
comportements inappropriés peuvent mener
un congédiement
même s'ils surviennent à l'extérieur du
travail surtout lorsqu'ils sont filmés
je suis béni martin chabot radio canada
montréal